[Musique]
sept ans de crise requins et ce soir
dans un jour avec le témoignage d'un
rescapé il ya un peu plus de deux ans
rodolphe arié guy a eu le bras arraché
par un squale alors qu'il surfait à
saint leu il dut donc réapprendre à
vivre avec le bras qui lui restait sous
le quotidien il en parle avec humour et
philosophie avec impatience également à
car il attend toujours une prothèse avec
l'espoir de reprendre un jour le surf
jean marc collienne et laurent fignon le
rencontrer il est arrivé dans l'île il
ya plus de vingt ans pour surfer la
réunion dit il c'était un extraordinaire
terrain de jeu à la réunion n'avait
toutes les conditions pour surfer toute
l'année quoi 300 jours par an
du lundi au dimanche jusqu'à ce jour de
juillet 2015 tous les jours la moelle et
fall grosses vagues les vagues d'un
mètre à mettre 20 la voilà au début de
la vague là où il ya la mousse la mousse
blanche pas qu'ils déroulent voilà c'est
un petit gars comme ça voilà à d'autres
à cette hauteur là on va vous donner je
m'allonge sur la planche et l'âge je
passe mon bras la lotus a été soudain
j'ai senti quelque chose m'a agrippé le
bras
ça m'a légèrement basculée la porte le
surf
là j'ai vu la tête du requin et c'est
bien de deux secondes quoi là on voit
plus la scène était une image de
match de terreur là je suis parti sous
l'eau avec lui je me suis débattue gers
et à ramer
jusque sur le récif corallien je me suis
échoué sur le coup tu as pensé que je
pouvais y rester ah oui c'est me 6002
dont le cerveau il n'a pas le temps de
compter jusqu'à 2 c'est une image match
de mort
on perd la vie quoi c'est pourquoi pas
qu'on pense à rodolphe a eu la vie sauve
grâce à un ami surfeur qui lui a fait un
gars mais il a fallu l'amputer du bras
droit
aujourd'hui il vit seul dans un petit
appartement avec vue sur la gauche de
5,9 au quotidien ça s'est passé comment
l'apprentissage de la vie avec un seul
bras bah disons qu'on vous apprend pas
tellement c'est cesser d exercice ça
donne naturellement quoi ça vient
naturellement à pro fur et à mesure
voilà on trouve des astuces et puis ça
ça vient le plus dur ça serait lavez
lavez lavez une toile mais bon on y
arrive le heureusement qu'il y a qu'à
raqqa 10 cm ça sert comme passe là le
fait d'être comme ça bon moi je peux
m'en servir 15 qui n'aiment pas sûr
qu'aller faire 50 ah c'est sûr que
j'avais une chérie ça serait mieux comme
ça il y en a qui fait la vaisselle et
puis et puis l'autre personne qui a
ménage deux ans et demi après son
accident
rodolphe en parle avec le sourire il
arrive même à les hanter mais il ne
cache pas que c'est parfois très dure
non non mais je présente mon nez ça y
est c'est pas évident ben c'est surtout
que quelqu'un quand il fait à quatre en
cinq heures de sport par jour
on voit bien que le cerveau il est quand
même habitué à l'espace bien-être
c'est ce à quoi vous quand on ne rate on
aurait très bas
la nervosité horreur qu'on a
ouais c'est ça il ya des orgas bien sûr
que bon euro on a chacun nos problèmes
s'est amplifiée quoi donc du coup faire
du sport savons palliatifs est tous dans
l'appartement rappelle à quel point
rodolphe aime le sport il a même juste à
côté de son lit la planche sur laquelle
il a été attaqué c'est mon fils qui a
voulu récupérer la planche bon ça va je
fais pas de cauchemars sur les requins
ça c'était la planche quand le récit
fait je me suis fait attraper par leur
carte
et depuis rodolphe attend une prothèse
qui lui permettrait de s'adonner à son
autre passion le cyclisme
donc là le vélo mais elle est où la faim
et date de 2015
ça fait trois ans que j'attendais
une prothèse malheureusement c'est ça je
tombais sur une entreprise on va dire de
dison de haute technologie mais qui font
surtout du commerce résultat la première
prothèse ne convenait pas la seconde
qu'il recevra bientôt devrait permettre
à rodolphe de reprendre enfin le sport
mais il a perdu près de 3 à l'aller
avait une planche là qui était faite en
fin de compte c'était pour s'entraîner
pour les championnats de france de surf
car très vite rodolphe a voulu reprendre
la compétition
mais avec la crise requins et
l'interdiction de surfer il n'a jamais
vraiment pu s'entraîner tu étais
droitier gt gt droitier
j'aurais appris à écrire de la main
gauche voilà au journal j'ai rendez-vous
à aux orteils ce matin au golf a
rendez-vous à la caisse d'allocation
familiale à saint louis
car son allocation adulte handicapé ne
lui a pas été versés en début de mois
et c'est pratiquement son seul revenu un
peu plus de 800 euros
[Musique]
les avait suspendues ce sens suite à une
erreur informatique donc ça a été repris
bon on est soulagé c'est une histoire
qui règle aujourd'hui tu vis avec eux
quels moyens financiers lâche mais 107
euros tous les aides les aides au
logement les apl
200 250 euros et n'a plus pu travailler
depuis un accident kazim
elle a depuis l'accident non j'ai une
proposition de travail le
au mois de novembre mais j'étais la
personne sur tellement contrarié par ce
prime de 30 est ce qu de santé que je
veux régler donc
je veux d'abord régler simplement
apprendre des choses et en attendant
rodolphe essaie de garder la forme
[Musique]
quand je repense au jour de l'accident
qui dit j'aurais pas dû aller j'étais
inconsciente il ya des regrets non jeu
ça fait partie du
du risque à la mer c'est un danger donc
moi j'ai appris ça tout seul des gens au
pays basque avec les courants les baïnes
tu peux arriver tellement de choses
dans la merde ça fait partie des
probabilités mais retourner à l'eau pour
nager tu es retourné assez vite ou non
pour nager c'était assez rapide par
contre petite appréhension quand je
nageais dans le lagon
desjoyeaux un poisson un peu plus gros
qu'un autre cas une fois je suis tombé
sur une horaire la gt gt paniqué quoi
ouais j'ai eu des flashs comme ça un peu
noir au début du mois c'est parti ça va
quand tu vois les blagues la salle des
manchots se bat là j'aimerais bien y
aller là justement son bel belle journée
de surf la haie
bon après
bon on sait qu'on peut pas y aller
bon c'est facile dans le cirque de dalé
surf et jusqu'à 60 65 ans donc j'ai
encore de belles années de surf devant
maxime
[Musique]
rodolphe rêve même des jeux olympiques
et paralympiques où le sort sera présent
pour la première fois en 2000
et pour le moment
il doit se contenter de la caresse des
vagues
[Musique]